but when it comes to space exploration
and astronauts the Holy Grail is sorted
those items relating to Neil Armstrong
he's easily the most famous the most
iconic member of the astronaut team some
of the items that are most iconic would
be pieces of the famous Wright Flyer
airplane the first manned flight period
pieces of the cloth that were on the
fuselage and pieces of the prop that
also flew on the Apollo 11 mission
the most important consignment to this
particular sale are items consigned by
Neil Armstrong's family and these
include items that span all of Neil
Armstrong's life from notes that he
wrote as a small child all the way
through his his life as a Navy fighter
pilot and then on to his days as an
astronaut
you